hey the david pakman show appeared on a
dutch television recently i've
previously brought you clips of the
david pakman show on Canadian television
I've brought you multiple clips of the
David Pakman show on different French
television stations we have been on I
believe Israeli television and now the
David Pakman show has appeared on Dutch
television they did a story previewing
Donald Trump's medical exam from last
week and they used a clip of our show
and I love it because it's just it's
Dutch which I don't understand
interspersed with David Pakman and then
they actually play a clip check this out
consultation into 90s er from obtained
almost off Tennessee cash more her
omekata to Ayden savings of the Erica
fast food leaf ever Donald Trump they
made it destined by the ants lock up
again for some act gonna go to Walter
Reed Medical Center in Washington DC is
Friday he's going to be fully and
thoroughly examined by the same doctor
who examined President Obama the Mehdi
seminole dries more her ovary dammit
President Donald Trump oz portions very
chilly and Shaina fit exactly I could
not have said it better myself
I really like the sound of Dutch I do
it's almost like and this is I want to
be super clear I'm not saying anything
critical or offensive about about
anybody here but it's almost like it's
German like but it's way less harsh to
the ear in some way and there yeah and I
hope I'm not being offensive when I say
that no I don't think so
and to be fair I think anything sounds
better with like a drumbeat behind it oh
yeah like a pop style thing no yeah it's
like a driving a forward moving beat
that really keeps the momentum going
during the news so anyway the
Netherlands and I assumed when someone
emailed me saying you were on Dutch TV
that it was going to be related to our
coverage of Dutch and ambassador to the
Netherlands pete hoekstra and his no go
burning of politicians comments but it
wasn't it was actually Dutch coverage of
the trunk medical exam also of interest
to them interesting I hope next time
that you're dubbed instead of just
subtitles nobody could be interesting
yeah who would be who would play my
Dutch voice that would be an interesting
thing all right we will take a break
we've got a great interview coming up
for you today and then a lot more
stories to talk about I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the
Joe was on Twitter at David Pakman show